[Music]
we continue now with our series
i on earth our planet in peril the
second day of the biden administration's
global climate summit is underway this
morning
leaders from around the world are
meeting virtually to try and curb the
planet's carbon output
yesterday president biden recommitted
the united states to cut our greenhouse
gas emissions by 50 percent
by the end of this decade and china
reaffirmed its pledge
to be carbon neutral by 2060 climate
activists and scientists say we can
still take measures to slow the warming
of the planet before it's too late
but climate researchers also have
evidence that we are dangerously close
to a number of catastrophic tipping
points joining us now to discuss the
science is cbs news meteorologist and
climate specialist jeff beridelli
jeff these tipping points you've spoken
to researchers about them
what are they break it down i have to
tell you it's concerning unanimously
all these scientists say that we are
much closer to tipping points than we
thought we were just a decade
or two ago and one of those we're very
close to
is the amazon rainforest so the amazon
rainforest has been around
for 55 million years but it's crazy to
think that in just
one century human civilization could
completely
wipe it out so far we have deforested 20
percent
of the brazilian amazon let me tell you
why that's important
because the amazon rainforest is only a
rainforest because it is a rain
making machine it produces 50 percent of
its own rain and the way that it does
that is
it exhales from the leaves and the
canopy all that water vapor into the
atmosphere
causes a river of clouds and rainfall to
fall
so it's a self-sustaining system however
as we begin to break apart the amazon
into pieces all those fires that you see
we reduce the ability of the leaves and
the trees to create its own rain
and believe it or not scientists say and
the foremost experts say
that we could see this lush wet
rainforest transition to a savannah
in only 20 to 30 years and vlad the
reason why that's so important is
because think about all the biodiversity
in the amazon we lose a lot of that and
also think about all the carbon that is
stored there
billions of tons would be released into
the atmosphere making climate change
even worse
let's talk about antarctica we've all
seen those heartbreaking images of polar
bears
trying to find a place to land while
they're swimming through the ocean
what does the rising temperatures in
antarctica mean what else is troubling
about that
so antarctica is a canary in a coal mine
it has ice miles thick and if all that
ice would have melt
that would be 200 feet of sea level rise
now it has been stable for a very long
time and scientists thought it was
stable
but a few years ago they started to
notice a rapidly evolving situation
in west antarctica specifically swedes
glacier
and pine island glacier starting to
become less
stable let's talk about why that's the
case the reason is that we have warm
water water temperatures have been
warming in the oceans by two three four
degrees fahrenheit
it's getting underneath these glaciers
which stick out very far
over the ocean waters that's breaking up
the ice shelves like a dam the dam is
beginning to burst and once that happens
it's like pulling a wine cork out of a
wine bottle all that ice flows from land
into the ocean raises
sea levels those two glaciers have four
feet of sea level rise not going to
happen next decade or the decade after
but by the end of the century
we could see several feet of sea level
rise swamping
hundreds of millions of people who live
along the coast that's a big deal
a lot of people will say look this is
happening on the other side of the world
i live here in new york city what does
this mean for me yeah so the problem
here in the north atlantic is we have
something called the atlantic
meridional overturning circulation the
gulf stream
system now the gulf stream we know about
it it produces warm water brings it up
from the gulf of mexico it's responsible
for redistributing
20 percent of the heat from the warm
tropics to the poles
now this is beginning to slow down and
it's a big deal because it is a linchpin
in the climate system
near greenland what we really need to
run this engine is
dense cold salty water it sinks runs
that engine but
greenland is beginning to melt and as
greenland begins to melt
we're seeing that fresh water flow into
the north atlantic
fresh water doesn't sink as well so the
whole conveyor belt is slowing down it
slowed down 15
since 1950 could slow down by 45 percent
by the end of the century that could tip
it stop
the current and that would throw weather
patterns in the north atlantic from the
east coast to europe completely off
kilter
raised sea level rise remember this
right here is a linchpin it controls the
whole climate system
that's a big deal all right so it's a
little troublesome
maybe a big trouble but there's got to
be some silver linings
well for the amazon rainforest if we can
start reforesting
right now all the countries need to work
together we can help to save it but it
has to happen soon we're very close to a
tipping point
everything else we need to reduce the
warming of the planet flat we reduce the
warming of the planet
we can slow these impacts they'll still
happen gradually but more gradually
it will give us time to adapt well what
we saw yesterday is a first step in the
right direction absolutely yeah sure
jeff beridelli thank you very much